[Music]
it was
what is this right now who loves so much
guys we like much
do you remember your first time jacking
off yeah I do I was doing it like I was
starting a fire I was like
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of the trash days podcast I'm
Joey and as always I'm with gone and Sea
Dog hello my lies he's gone and why am I
see it yo because you got the dog in you
know you got that dog
I hope I don't you don't want the dog in
you no isn't that like a sexual term now
what okay so it's been like dreams
change too fast I always thought it was
just like he's like the cool kid I
thought it always meant yo this like
it's it's a guy who will perform Under
Pressure like when no matter what you
know because he got that dog in him but
I I don't actually know because I
actually just uh guessed that out of
Googling it I thought I thought it was
just like I thought it's like a
substitute for rizz okay like he's got
the wrist he's got the Italian you know
okay so like new words pop up all the
time when did Riz become a thing because
I'm like I just want to I just want to
make sure that my first time hearing Riz
and your guys's time do match up or if
I'm just like out of touch I you know I
don't even know anymore man like with
how fast memes are moving nowadays like
yeah I don't every new every other week
There's a new word that people are just
saying on Twitter I'm like what what did
I miss and I feel like I feel like the
fact that I'm seeing it on Twitter means
I'm two months out of when this actually
started somewhere else on the internet
probably on Tick Tock or something right
I try to find the thing of the dog the
thing of the dog
I don't know I don't you know I just I
typed in dog and I just showed up yeah
just pretend like I know what's
happening and I just say the words
[Music]
like where did Riz come from uh some
there's no the thing is because we're
like man what did this come from but
then there's probably like some really
well detailed history of where exactly
it came from and when it started being
used because that's how it always is
yeah it's just probably more meaningful
wait for the one hour doc YouTube
documentary of the the history of
Rizzo a lesson in meme culture yeah yeah
because like I don't know sometimes a
word just makes sense you know like okay
the first time I heard drip I'm like I
get it I don't even know like I don't
even know the full context of it but
I've had this exact same time have we
actually you said you said and I swear
you've said this exact same sentence
with drip is the example oh my God hey
man we're 150 years
I started saying this and I was like no
Deja Vu we've had this I have heard this
conversation before so you've said this
yeah okay
I I think we've had this exact
conversation I think I think we have
this conversation every time last time I
was busing right and we had this whole
conversation about what has that died
yes no it kind of came back with that
whole like I'm busying meme right
what
it's such a horrible meme it's this it
comes from this gay porn
um and uh and it's just like a dude who
is uh obviously not a native English
speaker and uh and when he when he
passes a different it's a different
busing yeah
that is
so funny yeah but now it's like it used
to mean like oh man this shit's like
really good like like all this food is
busting right but now it just means
I don't think it does I mean in one
corner of the internet yeah I I I I
always took it that way I'm like if I
ate a piece of food I was like oh man
this is busting but now it just means
busting like this I I've never heard
someone I've never heard it in that
context I'll be honest no no
is this a tick tock thing it's
definitely a Twitter thing for sure all
right yeah yeah I don't know yeah
speaking of which like okay new topic I
hope we haven't talked about this maybe
we have before uh is it hard to make
friends in 2023 because I don't know
what like okay I live by the algorithm
so I don't know if YouTube shorts thinks
that I don't have many friends
but so it's like you've been watching
too many YouTube shorts uh you clearly
have no friends yeah so I've been
recommended uh a lot of shorts recently
just about like you know this [__]
streets interviews that uh uh that
happened and there's just been like a
bunch of shows I've been recommended
about just people talking about do you
have any real friends or how many how
many real friends do you have in your
life right okay are you okay are you
okay I'm okay we need to hang out I'm
okay you know I'm saying I'm okay but I
find it interesting seeing all these
YouTube shorts and uh I think uh like
Finland Franco did a like news article
recently oh yeah like loneliness is like
[__] yeah yeah
how like in this day and age more like
more I think I don't I don't know if
it's more men or just more people in
general uh are more lonely and single
than they're like in in like the history
of like
I'm not too sure about those statistics
right because it's like I think about
that
I love that okay I'm sorry I was like
you know my opinion yeah you know uh
facts
in my opinion those facts are
questionable yeah it's like I'm calling
this episode yeah because like you know
I feel like with like the social media
and everything right and the internet
and we've had this conversation like way
way earlier on in a in a podcast episode
about like our online friends considered
real friends right yeah and like I feel
right but that's also a point of
contexture of like a lot of people who
are just like terminally online do see
online friends as like real friends
because maybe they don't have like
actual IRL friends I think we should
discern what you mean by online friends
that's something you've never met or is
it yeah well you know it could be like
uh you know someone you talk to every
day on like Discord or like you know
someone you uh talk to consistently on
on Twitter or Instagram and you know
maybe you've met them once IRL but yeah
you know for the most part you met them
online I think that changes for social
media that changes how you look I mean
just not to get stuck in the in the
details here but I think if you've met
someone and then you talk a bunch online
yeah it's where it makes way more sense
because there's like okay we've met up
and there's probably that expectation
that we'll meet up again but if you've
never met up and you're only talking
online then I think there is a question
of like okay well is that a real friend
yeah well it's uh this is weird yeah I
mean well because there's a lot of
people you know even in our personal
lives of like we've only talked to them
online you know we've interacted with
them online but we've never actually met
IRL yeah right but that doesn't mean
that they're any less of a friend than
say like us three or anyone you actually
meet irr yeah okay so Theory here
um so I I was I was kind of memeing when
I said no but kind of like also half not
meaning yeah uh because uh we we we're
friends right we have a lot of friends
right we we're with social people right
but
um like kind of kind of like the vibe I
got from all of these Tick Tock uh
[__] YouTube short like rabbit who I
went through was that a lot of people
nowadays have acquaintances
um but there's very like the people that
you would actually call like your real
friends is like kind of like on the
decline okay so then what is the what is
the border between a friend and an
acquaintance that's okay that's that's
that's the real question right that's
the real question how many people in
your life would you actually consider
like a real friend versus someone you uh
someone you hang out with and where do
you draw the distinction in that right
and for me personally at least for me
it's someone that I can feel totally as
as an introvert right it's someone I can
feel totally comfortable just being
myself yeah and not fearing being judged
or having like having that little
barrier to be like having that little
voice to be like can I say this in front
of this person I don't know because I
don't know them that I mean I don't know
where their boundaries yeah I don't know
where their boundaries are so I don't
know how far I can push the boundary so
I can you know I can call you guys
[__] uh to whatever and I'm like I I
know you guys can take it you've just
been downgraded to all queens sorry
sorry you're probably gonna have to uh
[__] beat that up because of
YouTube's uh YouTube Laura and
everything like that but you know some
some people you're still like feeling
the water about where your like
boundaries are and uh that to me is when
I can call someone like a true mate you
know right right someone that's I can
hang out with any not just hang out but
actually talk with uh talk to them about
anything and not have to feel like I
have to play a certain let's say role
like when we hang out so
is okay now is there okay because often
these surveys and stuff they ask not how
many acquaintances is today how many
friends you have any close friends do
you yeah yes yeah so that's the barrier
would you say for you to be friends and
then what would a close friend be okay
or would you do you consider all friends
close friends I consider all friends
close friends how many how many friends
would you say then you have
because this is like a common Yeah
question that you also get asked in
these questions yeah yeah
um I would actually say I have quite a
lot of friends
um that I consider myself close with
okay I mean
I mean okay here's here's the thing for
example uh everyone who are invited to
my wedding was is at least like if not
like a very very close friend someone
that I consider pretty very very
comfortable and I had like like you're
in like the 40 50 plus range yeah I have
like it's okay so it's got the dog but
here's the thing I feel like really
really lucky but the reason okay so
compared compared to a lot of other
YouTubers and a lot of other twitch
streamers that I uh talk to online in
the online space I actually like keep
and I'm actually not too social on my
let's say professional side a lot of
twitch streamers are very very close
friends with their fellow streamers or
YouTubers or something like that and I
am an I am not someone who spends a lot
of time speaking to a lot of other My a
lot of other fellow creators unless they
are [__] you guys basically and I
realize part of the reason for that yeah
part of the reason for that is just
because I've kind of like with the
friends I have now with the friends I
have back home abroad and like the
people I feel close to I'm like at kind
of like not a cap but it's hard I'm
friendship doubt yeah yeah
it's hard to keep up with what everyone
is doing
you only have so much time in a day and
if if you're a close friend I actually
want to be a close friend to you as well
and that friendship takes effort you
know it does sure I also think we have
to acknowledge that we're in a very
unique position uh where there are more
people who let's say want to talk to us
then maybe we want to talk to other
people yeah
um not saying that like fans are friends
or anything like that but you know
there's always people kind of
approaching us or meetings you're always
kind of like even doesn't work or not
you know you always meet people so I
think having that stress removed from
you know we never have to I I've no I
have no concern in the world about am I
am I going to meet enough people I'm
like okay I'm gonna meet too many evil
now
right yeah so I think that that's
important to acknowledge when we discuss
this yeah um
uh in terms of loneliness in general or
lack of friendship in general that's
tough I think I I think male loneliness
is a male loneliness specifically is
higher nowadays yes if you ask how
people feel yeah I don't know loneliness
has to be a feeling right I mean it's
not it's not like a I mean you are we
don't just go around and be like gone
I've tried out your friend list you're
[__] lonely I have diagnosed you with
loneliness it's like people say they're
lonelier lonelier and I don't know what
that means does that mean they're just
unhappier and they feel them like yeah
but that's the thing right it's like
it's it's really hard to also we are not
Professionals in this thing completely
our opinion we are really our
prerogative but we also live in a lonely
country so yeah exactly exactly so yeah
so like understand this is completely
our prerogative and you know and many
people can take this in many different
ways but like when when I saw like the
statistics of like oh loneliness has
gone up I'm like can you like even
quantify something that is like pretty
subjective like because you know there's
I'm sure there are people who have two
friends but do not say that they're
lonely because they're very content with
just having a small group of friends and
then there may be some people who have
maybe you know 10 or 20 years would say
like oh but I don't have 100 friends so
I'm lonely right I mean it's loneliness
I guess is what it's not so much about
how many friends you have or whatever
that is it's like it's just like the
quality of the Friendship yeah well it's
like if they they're asking these people
hey do you think you're lonely and
they're like yes and I guess it doesn't
matter how many friends or whatever they
have because you could have 500 friends
and feel that you don't have a deep
connection with any of them right and be
lonely right yeah I'll be a very popular
person but feel like you can't really
connect to any of those people
um so I think it's it's kind of a
talking about how many friends you have
is not so much important I think a lot
of these when I've read all these stuff
a lot of them tend to be focused on more
like how many meaningful friendships
yeah yeah that's where a lot of people
uh not everyone but a lot of people get
their kind of core satisfaction or a lot
of the satisfaction in their life from
those like two to five people yeah who
are like these are the people you
probably turn to the most about a lot of
things yeah
um I think that's true for me as well
the more I think about it I'm like yeah
I I often don't want to talk about all
of my stuff to everyone it's like
there's probably a few people who I
would talk to about certain things more
more often than not right because you're
like I don't want to give everyone the
[__] run down every single time yeah
I mean like you want someone who gets it
you're like all right let's let's talk
right yeah yeah yeah
um that being said I think that there's
a lot of
um the coronavirus definitely
kicked into high gear loneliness oh I'm
like a crazy scale also I think uh
people growing up now I've also had a
harder time like let's say especially
people who are like just leaving High
School yeah who then got thrust into the
coronavirus where they're like oh you
were supposed to go to college
um no you couldn't and now it's like you
now you have to do zoom and it's like
okay well you missed out on a lot of
very important maybe uh social learning
opportunities and I think a lot of
people also just lost a lot of friends
during covert because you just didn't
even if they didn't like fall out or
anything it's like you just didn't hang
out and that's like and I think as we
get older we realize uh that maintaining
a friendship is probably
the hardest part about having friendship
it's not about making friends it's about
yeah am I seeing this person enough to
be on like good terms or to feel like
we're actually friends and I think that
was the thing that was affected a lot
during the pandemic and it's kind of
snowballed and I and I think that that
to me is the big thing
that's all good points because like like
the reason I say that I mean I'm very
blessed I think with my friendship
groups that I found uh because one of
the big reason is we've we have hung out
a lot in the past uh I've moved country
now I've moved countries now so I don't
get to talk or hang out with them as
often as maybe when I lived in England
or you know when I lived in the same
country as them but I always there's
always that Mutual trust between the
both parties that when we meet up we can
still talk about anything nothing's
changing things can be completely
comfortable
um and that's like that's that's the big
differentiator for me
um when I finally understood what it
means to have like a lifetime friend you
know because everyone has different
[__] priorities is everyone's doing
different [__] in their lives you can't
always be next to your friend or be
hanging out every week everyone's
adulting everyone's adulting right and
to me an adult friendship is having that
trust and respect for each other that
you can you can have the same connection
even if even if you haven't talked to
each other for like a few months even if
we haven't seen each other for a year
yeah the moment you hang out you're like
[__] it's it's all it's all the stuff
that's definitely for me my distinction
between a friend and a good friend like
a good friend is someone that you can
like not text or call or interact with
for like months or even years at a time
and then the next time that a text or a
call or a meet-up is set it's like
nothing has changed yeah and you can
just go right back to where you were in
that same mentality of the last time you
saw them or the last time you called
them right yeah I think we're also very
fortunate in our position uh that we
don't have to work a nine to five that
makes definitely hanging out people
easier I mean I'd argue with working
longer
but we're more flexible yeah we don't
have a boss yeah if a friend has like a
wedding you know we can be like yeah
I'll come to the wedding and yeah that's
no problem right whereas maybe another
friend couldn't go because they they
have work obligations I think maybe we
probably do work more in terms of like
if you're just looking at hours spent
it's yeah it's yeah we probably choose
we probably work a lot over time
competitive thing but we doesn't feel
like that because we like our job it's
easy we [__] a lot of the time it's
very it's not tough yeah um but I think
that that's a very important uh
distinction to make when us three
specifically are talking about this kind
of topic because you know it's
being able to be like yeah [__] it I'll
come drink on a Wednesday like that's
like that's a a thing that we can do and
we can decide if we're capable of doing
that whereas maybe your other friend is
like I gotta go I gotta go home it's 10
p.m yeah yeah tomorrow you know and as
long as we have that but I think that
that also plays a part in our
flexibility that allows us to kind of
maintain friendships more oh I mean I
mean it's funny because you know most
most of the friends I hang out with
um you know that I do consider close
um I do I do normally do like the nine
to five schedule
um in fact a big problem has been
sometimes when friends have assumed that
I have more free time just because my
schedule yeah yeah but I found that I
find that having a schedule having a
flexible schedule as a YouTuber uh means
that I get more time to hang out with
other YouTubers yeah you know it doesn't
doesn't necessarily yeah you know what I
mean I know yeah yeah it ends up
happening a lot because I often you just
can't hang out with people all the time
who are looking done fives yeah so
they're so busy yeah it's like YouTube
is the only people who can like let's go
[__] get lunch on a Tuesday yeah
right like right we can do that and I
think that's yeah that's like a very
fortunate thing of our job yeah
um because like okay so like another
thing I've noticed is that I feel like
part of the reason is I feel like
there's a lot of tools in the modern day
and age that kind of can act as
friendship simulators or loneliness like
parasocially I mean or not not just not
not even like not even just like Paris
socially but something to make you trick
to trick yourself into making you feel
less lonely even though on their own
distractions yeah it's called
distractions
you know I think we grew up when that
was all kicking off yeah you know we we
had the internet we had games uh and at
the time there was a lot of speculation
from like Boomers being like damn these
kids they're just not learning the life
lessons that we needed and you know I
think it's a lot of [__] horseshit I
think
most people manage to have a completely
well adapted life but the more it goes
on the and the older we get the more I
think yeah I mean I I had a fine time
with it but I think a lot of people
probably did not adapt as well as they
could have yeah because they were so
surrounded by video games and I realized
I was kind of fortunate that my parents
did force me a bunch to socialize or go
out even if even when I hated it like
yeah I did not want to yeah at all I
[__] despised it yeah but I realized
Now That I'm Older I'm like that was
probably necessary that my parents
[__] pulled my Xbox plug out and
forced me to go yeah yeah like it sucks
to admit because I'm like damn this
Boomers a little bit a part of me thinks
that they were kind of right like yeah
like I think if I had unfettered access
to just playing [__] Mini Clip games
like nine hours a day and I didn't talk
to anyone I'd probably be a little weird
yeah and I you know I think I think it's
uh because we just don't know we have no
idea what is gonna happen from all this
online uh access that no no I'm not
playing so the fact that we're just
distracted 24 7 we don't really have to
worry about being lonely because you
could also like let's be honest like if
you're feeling a little bit lonely just
[__] boot up a game and you'll be
you'll be distracted until you fall put
on a twitch stream watch trash days you
know watch a movie yeah and like that
does it for the most part but then I
guess after a while of that it may be
that those emotions kind of creep in and
be a bit too overwhelming right yeah and
then you're not prepared for it it's
just I don't know it's a it's I find
that we've we kind of we like adopted
all this stuff and all this uh way of
living and we didn't really think about
how it kind of affected us and now even
I'm like you know I sometimes I'm
watching [__] I'm like man I wish I just
was hanging out with people instead but
I'm too deep in the source yeah okay
it's weird it's such a weird thing that
I'm battling with and trying to
understand myself okay it's almost like
you don't know what exactly you want
right it's like because you're content
in the moment of like oh yeah you know
this game is sick or like um you know
watching this YouTube it's like
procrastination right like I know I need
to do something but I also know that uh
I can fool myself by playing games for
two hours yeah and I'm like what is that
what what like what is happening in my
brain there where I'm able to do that
yeah to like push that thing away and
not worry about it because like I was
watching these YouTube videos where
people would
um it was like a guy great I forgot the
name of the channel it's really good
video uh in general this whole Channel
he just basically just coached people
for their finances who just [__] up oh
yes I've seen that and it's like these
people you're watching them you know and
they would they would like get into like
really bad debt and they would just keep
making like really bad financial choices
yeah and then they'd be like hey did you
know you got to pay this bill to like
the IRS and they're like yeah I know I
you know I just haven't got around to it
and I'm like okay like I feel like that
pattern of pushing it away is exactly
what is like kind of stems from the same
behavior of like procrastination with
like video games or work where it's like
okay I don't want to deal with this
problem so I just distract myself and
hopefully I feel better for at least x
amount of time so I remember again yeah
I have to start myself again there's it
reminded me of like the same kind of
behavioral pattern but just way bigger
impacts on your life detrimentally yeah
yeah than opposed to just
procrastinating yeah I used to have such
a bad problem with that when I was a kid
like I always like whenever my parents
would ask me to do something or I had
like some like homework obligations or
you know some obligations I had as a kid
and you know I'd always have this bad
habit of being like ah yeah I'll just do
it tomorrow yeah so I'll still tomorrow
I'll do it the next day and my mom like
said it best she's like if you say you
can do it tomorrow you can do it today
yeah yeah and like that kind of made me
realize like oh [__] yeah I'm like this
is a bad habit to get in in any aspect
Financial or not any aspect just be like
don't it's it's just it's copious like
don't don't Huff the copium you know
like you gotta if there's [__] you gotta
do then you got to do it yeah because
like you know even for me like as uh I
think I'm like a [__] heavy introvert
right
um I think I'm very lucky now to you
know be married uh and I always have
someone who's a [__] version
imagine being married no like every time
I'm feeling just a tiny bit lonely I can
just hang out with Sydney who's also my
best friend at the same time and I'm
just like I never feel lonely anymore
and that's just like I know I'm blessed
and I feel that because every time
Sydney takes her either I'm on uh I'm
away from Sydney or she's on her work
holiday or something even if it's just a
week I have like after about after like
after like the first three days of like
the honeymoon period I'm like I can do
whatever I want I'd have to I'd have to
worry I can watch all the anime I wanted
Sydney's watching
and after that period is over I'm like
damn the house is really empty right now
yeah who do I who do I who do I talk to
and then and then then that's the point
when I start like messaging people to
hang out more often uh you can normally
tell when I when I'm feeling that like
void in my life
um because I think uh a big part of it
is that I think I think it was when in
University when I first started to
really feel the loneliness uh creep in
because you know in University you was
like surrounded by so many people and I
couldn't no matter how many people I was
surrounded with I could never stop that
feeling of just like loneliness uh
because I wasn't so socially adjusted
back then because going into like from
high school to University
um so like to basically combat that I
remember I just like I had this like
month period where I just tried to go
out like almost every single day and
hang out with who met who met whomever I
think that's I think that's like because
I did that did you do that as well I
think that's just like a thing that
every College shouldn't goes throughout
one point in their life yeah it's just I
think that's just like Universal with
all college students because yeah I did
that exact same thing yeah it's like
yeah it just kind of came over me one
day and I was just like [__] I'm like
I'm just like not doing anything yeah
and there's like no one around me you
should probably go out and like meet
people yeah and I because because now
like I feel like you know we talked
about our online friends real friends
and yes they definitely can be real
friends but I think there is nothing
that can be substituted for hanging out
with someone like IRL yeah absolutely
yeah they're like physical that's human
touch yeah that human touch because I
because I feel like you know even
sometimes when we talk in Discord when
we're doing like a like a kind of collab
or something on something the dynamic
just shifts like a little bit you know
what I mean there's some there's like
there's something that's missing there
that you don't get that's a big reason
why we want a trash taste to be IRL
right yeah exact reason you know I think
when you lose that like paying attention
to each other's eye contact or body
language or you know somebody paying
attention 100 like those are all things
that like really
don't exist when you're like on a zoom
call yeah because I can [__] play
video games and talk to someone like
yeah and I I can make it seem like I'm
paying attention 100 yeah not that it's
a good thing but because you know
because I I'm like oh yeah I'm it's like
it's not stimulating enough because
you're not like taking in all the senses
right yeah I don't know it's it's so I
it's so necessary to have that I think
um I think eye contacts like such a
massive thing yeah yeah I remember doing
like the Kobe times when you get on a
call with a mate that you haven't seen
for a while uh and then the camera would
just be like on the side like that you
just you just see them you look at each
other looking at a screen and not
looking at the camera right yeah and and
you were talking to each other but it
didn't feel like you were
there was a barrier there that I never
like could get used to like they're
hearing you but they're not listening
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm like are you
like like old top I'm not like second
monitor like content right now are you
[__] old Titans or YouTube right now
what are you doing man what are you
doing yeah
um and I feel like with a real human
connection
um there's there's nothing that just
substitutes hanging out in person being
there making eye contact with them and
sure you can you can you can have a fun
time hanging out online and stuff like
that
um but I feel like if you never meet up
in real life and you like and once you
meet up in real life it's kind of hard
to go back to online that's what I've
noticed yeah as well that's true yeah I
think that's why I find it so hard to do
like collabs with other content creators
whether it's like online because I've
just gotten so use with trash taste now
yeah and a lot of other content that we
do where we are hanging out IRL and it
feels so much more genuine to me right
yeah no for sure yeah I prefer in-person
collaboration yeah definitely more
worthwhile today's episode is sponsored
by PayPal honey the easy way to save
while shopping on your iPhone or
computer look at you watching this ad
right now where you can be saving on
some cold Hard Cash honey only takes a
few seconds to get that means if you add
it to your computer or iPhone right now
you could be done by the time this ad is
over and you know what I love getting
things done quickly and nothing works
faster than Honey's deal finding
abilities honey is a free shopping tool
that scales the internet for promo codes
and finds the best one it can find to
your cards alright guys the boys aren't
here right now so it's just gonna be me
and you what I want you to do is just
close your eyes now just imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite
websites you're at the checkout and what
you see is the honey button appears and
all you have to do is Click apply
coupons you'll wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons I could work
on that sites and you will watch as the
prices drop you know unlike the other
boys I'm a real weeb and what have I
been doing recently reading manga
especially online manga and I was
surprised that honey actually worked for
manga sites as well I saved a total of
ten dollars buying a bunch of manga
volumes online and the best thing is
honey doesn't not only work on your
desktop it works on your iPhone as well
just activate it on Safari and you will
save on the go getting honey only takes
a few seconds am I doing it you'll be
doing yourself a favor and supporting
the show as well so what are you waiting
for get paper honey today for free at
joinhoney.com trash taste that is
joinhoney.com trash taste thank you very
much to honey for sponsoring this
episode back to the video question to
you guys oh I haven't said that for a
while question question to you guys
how long has been since I said that all
right how much do you think First
Impressions actually matter
yeah doesn't like situation we're in
right I mean it's definitely important I
mean there's a there's a whole reason
why you know everyone and their mother
always says like oh you know make sure
your first impression is good because
that could last your entire friendship
if you you know if they can continue to
pursue it and everything like that but
also you know I've had moments where
I've met someone the first impression
wasn't you know the most like 10 out of
10 favorable thing ever but oh yeah
like this guy right here but you know
eventually over time you know you give
her the benefit of the doubt and yeah
you know you end up forming a very great
friendship right so and I've had
complete opposite instances of like the
first impression was like a 10 out of 10
like oh yeah I'm gonna be friends with
this person so hard and then a couple of
times after you kind of start to show
the the real side I guess because they
didn't show it on their first impression
and then you're just like oh
yeah you weren't you're not really as
cool as the first time I've met you yeah
okay counter question then okay to that
question because I feel like this is uh
this is like the the whole first
impression thing is it's kind of like
hinged on another way that I at least I
view conversation right is it like I
feel like a friendship isn't like formed
or at least isn't like uh like real
let's say I mean you're like your
acquaintances in my mind until there's
like something like shared information
then like you both share things yeah and
that it's like an equal sharing of uh
maybe personal information or you'd have
to be like here's my bank account
details
there's a deep dark secret yeah but it's
like sharing of of like maybe emotions
that could be vulnerable or maybe uh
just just kind of saying hey I trust you
to this other person and then they say
it back and it's like yeah I could hang
out with someone for 10 times and if I
feel like I just still don't know them
or don't know anything about them it's
like it doesn't mean [__] but someone
could overshare on the first time I'd be
like that's too much because now I feel
like you're too willing to share this
and so it's kind of like it's kind of
like how do you share information and
I've got what my question is going to be
it's more gonna be like okay how do you
how do you then judge
what that first impression means I guess
I've actually I've actually uh I've
actually gone did you just say what I'm
trying to say I've actually got a yeah I
I I kind of do understand what you're
trying to say yeah yeah
um because I've had this exact same it's
like a dance like if the person's too
closed off yeah you're like well we're
not friends yeah but if they're too open
you're like this is too much yeah and
it's just like how do you make the
perfect first impression
right and okay so I've thought about
this a lot and my Approach has changed I
guess as I've gotten older so when I was
younger I'd say like when you know when
I was in like my early 20s I I wouldn't
even say I'd met my first real friends
until I was about the age of 24 24 25
actually so I would say actually pretty
late I actually found what my meaning of
like oh I I understand what people means
when they say a true friend right so
before I would wait I would be way more
conscious about trying to set the
perfect good like first impression like
in my mind uh like as you said maybe
trying to think
I wouldn't worry about how it's coming
off I was yeah I was like I'm just gonna
be me and I'm sure that I know I'm not
like a dick whenever people so I'm like
I'll I'll be okay yeah uh I mean I'll
just worry about just having a good time
yeah and I think back then it was
because I was just because I didn't
really have many friends I would call
you know true friends I would just try
to befriend everywhere yeah yeah you
know you you trying yeah I was exactly
the same I think I think that's very
common when you're like in your teens
you everyone for the most part unless
you're like a true [__] like I think
everyone just wants to be a people
pleaser everyone wants everyone to like
me yeah exactly how do I do that I give
off a first impression that I kind of
gauge maybe this is the kind of person
that this person wants to see in me
exactly right but yeah they're gone yeah
I mean I didn't think too much about
whether I actually wanted to be their
friend I just wanted more friends you
know so I wanted to say I just wanted
people to like you yeah exactly you just
want people to like you you know that's
still that's that that side of me is
still like never gotten away it's never
nice to think that [__] that person
definitely hates me now or something
it's never a nice feeling but
um you know as I've got an older as I've
you know have more friends that I feel
comfortable with and everything I just
find out that you know I think this must
be an age thing where you just find you
just have less patience uh with people
you know and you have less care about
trying to be friends with everyone
so now that I'm at this stage I think
First Impressions actually mean a lot
right because sometimes you do you kind
of like you do you kind of tell off like
not even like even if you don't talk to
someone do you sometimes like see
someone in like a new group a table and
you're like I think I would vibe with
you and I don't know why do you have do
you ever have that no no for sure yeah
yeah yeah and normally like my kind of
like your my like sixth sense that I've
guessed like you've you know honed over
time I've kind of like been able to pick
up on like subtle subconscious cues
where I'm like I think I would vibe with
this person based on the way they said
this one sentence or the way they talk
and I don't know why but I just have I
just have that feeling and most of the
time it ends up being true right uh and
it's not really about you know sending
because it's not really about have they
said a good first impression it's more
about just you kind of get like the same
you kind of get the energy of someone
now that we've hang out with like enough
people IRL yeah you're probably I think
it's I think it's the due to the fact
that like you know you're able to kind
of you've because you've met so many
different people with so many different
personality traits and you've eventually
seen how those personality traits end up
when they you know show their true
selves I guess when you become friends
with them right I think just from that
you're you have a better understanding
as you get older of like you know
especially when it comes to First
Impressions at least with me I can kind
of tell if someone's giving off a first
impression
because they're either actually like
that in real life yeah or they're just
trying to show the best parts of
themselves yeah like there's there's
some First Impressions where I'm just
like okay I know you're like trying to
be friendly with me but I can just I
have a Vibe you are not this kind of
person yeah like in actuality right and
I don't know why and most of the time
I've got that right where I'm just like
oh yeah you you were kind of like just
trying to show off your first impression
that I would like because you really
wanted to be friends with me and I
appreciate that yeah but at the end of
the day I'm gonna be friends with people
who are honest with me when it comes to
their personality how do you know if
you're right how do you know if how do
you know if you're right I said use it
like most of the time you're right when
you're like I got a bad impression of
them how would you know you're right if
you did not trust or befriend someone I
don't again I've I've I think for me
personally I've just been in so many
situations where I've given them the
benefit of the doubt and then at the end
of the day they've betrayed me in some
way right and you know I've had a lot of
people backstab me in my life you know
because I was just trying to be friends
with everyone I gave everyone the
benefit of the doubt yeah but now that
I'm approaching 30 I've just gone to the
point where I'm like I don't have
[__] patience for this like yeah if
you don't if I don't get the vibe from
you that I'm gonna be be good friends
with you you know whether that be the
first time meeting or the 10th month
time meeting or the 100th time meeting
then I'm not even going to bother
pursuing this friendship yeah you know
and at the end of the day like I think
that's because I've seen enough people
now and I've seen enough personality
differences where I have a much better
understanding now in my life compared to
when I was in like high school of like
okay are you being legit right now are
you actually showing the side of me that
is you or are you showing the side of me
that I want you to see yeah if that
makes sense yeah because the the way I
that we are the way I approach it is you
know I only have I guess a certain
amount of social energy
so if if I get like the kind of like
vibe that I think like you know nowadays
if I'm like I think it's gonna take a
lot of social energy to hang out with
this one person and then I have them
like two or three times and I'm like
that was kind of exhausting not for not
from not because of anything they did
wrong just because I just think our
energies are like a little bit different
and sometimes when I'm like some of you
just don't gel with yeah sometimes you
just don't gel with someone and I that
used to bother me a lot because I'm like
I want to gel with everyone and now I'm
just like I gel with the people I gel
with because I can't help the person I
am you know and uh like I'm not gonna
change my personality for every other
different type of Personality trait just
because I want to be friends with them
yeah it's like I want to just be me and
if you don't [__] with me and my
personality then I'm not gonna bother
trying to show the best side of me
because that's just who I am and if you
don't want to be friends with me that
way hey you know what there's plenty of
fish in the sea yeah there's plenty of
other people you can gel with and it
just so happens that that person is not
me and that's fine you know yeah where
do you think where do you think people
can find friends in this day and age
because that's that's because like like
you said we are very we're very lucky
right we're very lucky to have a job
where we get to meet a lot of people a
lot of times Anime conventions Anime
conventions honestly for as much as much
as we clown on Anime conventions like I
think especially for people who like
anime and like weeb culture like I
genuinely think that is the best place
to meet people because it's like
shared interest yeah spaces you know
whether that be like you know any kind
of convention or like any kind of meet
up or you know just something IRL I
think is so [__] important for
especially kids in this day and age that
you know do I think I think the
blurriness of online friends and real
friends quote unquote is slowly getting
blurred by the day especially with like
the younger generation because to them
online friends are their real friends
yeah in a lot of instances right and you
know maybe it that is true but I think
again as as Conor was saying like you
need you need that human touch dude you
gotta you gotta you gotta interact with
people yeah yeah exactly there's always
like because now that I've had a few
experiences now where I've just
completely moved to a new city
um sometimes not knowing anyone it's
it's always like hard whenever you move
somewhere new especially you have like
if you have like established friendship
group back home you moved somewhere
totally new and you're like [__] I've
got to start from zero and find a new
friendship group here and that that
takes a lot of time and that takes a lot
of like energy I think the biggest the
Japan was more easy because like I had
like Geeks plus I had you guys uh the
hardest one for me was actually probably
Thailand uh because when I moved to
Thailand uh me and Sydney we we knew
family but I did not have any like Thai
friends yeah at all and you know
my my experience with that was I would
just have to go to as many meetups as
possible whether it be like you know
there's there's a lot of different
websites that you can use for different
meetups for certain specific let's say
you know niches or interests and I think
doing that is such like such a big
important factor into trying like giving
yourself the opportunity to make friends
yeah because if you never give if you
never go out of your comfort zone if you
are too lazy to just go out and put
yourself out there and meet people that
you have you know like you don't know if
you're gonna be friends or not
um then you're not going to make friends
and I think this needs to be said as
well of like I feel there's this when we
say like you know you should go to like
meetups or like conventions to like make
friends like I I think there's this like
weird social pressure to be like oh okay
I'm going to this convention this
weekend if I don't come back with at
least x amount of friends friends then
like I've wasted my time or whatever
which I think is just like not true like
I I think like the whole social pressure
of like I have to make friends again
here's the problem is if you're going if
you're going anywhere to
make friends you're already kind of
setting yourself up for failure that's
how think about every friendship you've
ever had it probably hasn't come from
you trying to make sure yeah yeah yeah I
mean you know there is no friendship
that has started with let can we be
friends let's be friends let's be
friends that's that's not how
friendships start friendships start
naturally just like you don't have to
ask the question it's just a mutual
agreement of like yeah your call you
think I'm cool hey I guess we're friends
now yeah and like I feel like even just
going to any kind of Meetup or
convention and maybe not necessarily
coming back with a concrete result of
like I made this many friends you know
maybe you it might have been zero I
think it's still good to go to those
kinds of places because you learn so
many skills to just like interact with
people and to like you know get in the
position of naturally making friends
because yeah you know again like no
friendship starts with the question of
can we be friends well that's not how it
works it's less about making friends
more about just finding people that you
can hang out with yeah because I feel
like yes another thing about making
friends online is that talking to people
talking to people online is easy mode
that's that's like that's like easy mode
right that's like socializing with
training skills uh with training wheels
in a sense right
um because you know when you're online
you can kind of like if it's via text
for for one then you can uh you can have
the time to think about what you're
gonna say it's the equivalent to passing
notes in a classroom yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's not communicating and uh again if
even if you're on call you can be
concentrating on something else and it's
just you know it's not always the same
kind of like Vibe uh as being there in
real life so yeah I mean I I think I was
I was firmly in that camp for a very
long time
um and then I guess just hanging out
with mouse has changed my opinion a lot
on it so I'm like okay well here's
somebody who just can't yeah leave their
house yeah and it's like okay would I
ever say that's not a real friendship no
absolutely nothing so it's like then
it's a situation of like okay well is
this just like a so I just how I view
this entire situation is it was I wrong
or am I just bending my the way I view
it just for one case I'm like it's kind
of weird because I think that it's it's
I think it's a personal preference of
each kind of person like individual you
meet like there probably some people who
you're fine talking to online and
there's probably some people who you're
like I don't really gel talking to you
on Discord like I never [__] talk to
you guys online on the call yeah I know
I'm like hang out with you guys in
person like I don't want to call you
guys yeah yeah so I think it's it's a
really odd distinction and I don't know
what that means or how that interacts
with my beliefs but yeah I thought it
was interesting that's what I mean like
I feel like because now those kinds of
friendships uh are getting more common
especially among younger people like I
feel that line is slowly getting blurred
to the point where it's like maybe
online friends are becoming real friends
just based on different you know like
prerogatives right like you know yeah in
the case like Mouse like you know she is
an online friend yes but she is also
your actual real friend as well right
yeah so it's like where's the
distinction in that I just think that if
if I had only had online friends up
until that point I would use a lot of
um I'd lose a lot of the ability to
learn like what I think are important
social skills uh you know like reading
body language reading you know when I
say something did they react badly to
that yeah knowing that like those little
cues or making enough eye contact you
know these are stuff that comes in handy
when you're you know when we're if we're
ever filming something and there's a
crew and it's like all right let's you
know like you you don't want to be a
dick like yeah be nice to everyone like
how do you how do you socialize people
in a meaningful way
um you know and if whenever I had jobs
or whatever I had to talk to people all
the time and it was like if I didn't
learn social skills before that I would
have been very very unprepared for that
and possibly have made a bad impression
or maybe I would have not been you know
wouldn't have got another job etc etc
you know a lot of a lot of the stuff
especially like voice acting and stuff
like that was all a lot of connections
and making good Impressions and it's
like okay a lot of the stuff you want to
do probably requires you to have great
social skills and if you've the only
experience you've had is via online you
might not be well prepared to then be in
a situation uh in in real life and be
kind of left your own social skills
because maybe you're just missing out on
things you didn't even consider about
right like and it's it's tough because
it's like okay well how do you how do
you learn that yeah because there's a
lot of situations where like you know I
think
people people have a lot more anxiety
nowadays yeah for a number of reasons
and it's like how do you you know if
you're an anxious person how do you how
do you learn those things how do you
push yourself to be uh to go out more
and interact more I don't know yeah for
me it was just trial by fire oh honestly
it's I because I I had social anxiety
and you know people might not believe me
but I was like that quiet kid yeah uh I
I was I I you know talking from
experience I was that [__] quiet kid
in high school I had like basically no
friends
um and I just like going into University
I was like I'm kind of tired of this
life I'm just [__] tired I'm so sh
I'm so socially anxious and I just
realized that if I don't commit to this
100 I'm not gonna commit to this at all
which is why I went to that phase where
I'm just gonna throw myself in every
awkward social situation I can think of
and there have been
so there are so many different uh
memories I have wiped from my mind uh
because it I was just you have to [__]
up
I was an awkward little [__] and
sometimes I just stay awake at night and
I just think about that one [__]
party I went to and I said that thing to
that guy and I was just like oh my God
why did I say that you know I've thought
about this so many times and I've always
said to people every time like people
worry way more about how they're coming
off than how you're coming off yeah
unless you say something [__] up like
a lot of people are just more worried
about how like again what they're saying
so like a lot of the time when you've
said something that maybe you thought
was really cringe they probably didn't
even give a [__] they were like what
yeah well maybe they thought it was
funny yeah they like pretty much paid no
mind to it they're like oh yeah I guess
you did you did do that one crazy thing
but I totally just didn't care like you
know what I mean like I think it's easy
to get in your own head with this kind
of stuff but also it's it's I guess you
can't just be like just don't be anxious
just do it just get over it I mean the
things
let's just go out you have to you have
to go out there and it sucks because you
know everything can always be traced
back to like when you're a kid and like
did you know uh did you get the right
experiences or yeah were you brought up
in a family that encouraged that kind of
stuff or yeah was your brain chemistry
just were you just born different like
was he saying that you were just you
were gonna struggle with your entire
life like these are all valid valid
questions yeah okay this is this is uh
such a we're going a bit off topic I
guess but did you guys have uh birthday
parties as kids or did you go to other
kids birthday parties uh yeah uh yeah I
did but I mean I was born in July so I
never got to have like uh like the
everyone turns up it's just yeah I got
like two kids oh yeah because everyone's
on my mine was always on school holidays
so I always had like a birthday party
yeah like yeah it was like it was you
know it started off at the McDonald's
playpen the goat
the ice cream cakes bro what's your
what's your reasoning fast no because
like I would always notice that the
people like the kids that ended up like
growing up to high school that had like
a big social group were the kids that
you know had like the biggest and most
kids come to their birthday parties you
know that's I don't know correlation I
don't know if that's just that's so
anecdotal that's completely anecdotal
that you are completely right this is
this is [__] data based on my one
personal experience I I was just like
huh because part of the reason I like
I've grown up really not hating my
birthday but just being really
indifferent about like my birthday and
having birthday parties part of the
reason for that was because uh I'm like
a late May baby so when my birthday came
around it was like exam season everyone
had to study so I wouldn't even try to
like have any birthday parties I think I
had like one as a kid
um and then it was birthday trauma yeah
it's like birthday trauma I'm like if I
don't invite anyone then I don't have to
be disappointed if no one comes to my
birthday because I know everyone's got
exams right
so I've I've grown up being like
completely indifferent about it
um and it's been interesting you know
meeting Sydney who's like the complete
opposite of just like I love my birthday
I I I always want to like this is like
the time I gotta hang out with my
friends and make it like some feel
special is she the person that calls it
a birthday month
no she only got that far she doesn't go
that far but uh she does always look for
something to make a birthday feel
special and she tries to give that to
other people as well and like haven't
seen like seeing that seeing that like
seeing seeing the other side of things
I'm just like damn that's a that's such
a small thing that I never got in my
life like having having like a small
thing of like having the birthday feel
special or doing something that goes out
your way to make that person feel
special but I'm like damn now that I've
seen now that I see her do it uh for
other people and see how she reacts when
she uh when you know I go out my way to
do something for her for her birthday is
what I'm like done like small things
actually matter you know a small thing
small things matter they build up yeah
they they build up and uh especially
when it comes to friendships going out
your way to make them know that you're a
friend or make them feel special that's
uh that's something that uh
some something that I've never really
thought about when I was growing up I
was like friends of friends you know
friends of friend but just making just
making your Bros feel special or making
and inviting people to hang out is a
very core part of friendship you know
yeah I can't always be that you know a
word of advice would be uh don't be that
guy who just waits for invitations
always you should always try and make
stuff yep you know not even if you're
like I don't know what to do she's like
you like hanging out with them right
yeah just hang out just just invite them
out yeah you know I think that's it
inviting people is one of the most
important parts of making someone feel
like they're you know a friend yeah yeah
they're like oh they considered me oh
they thought about me when they wanted
to spend time with people you know
that's that's like a really important
thing of course it's very easy to like
when I was a teenager I was like now
people just invite me to things yeah
passive guy yeah it was just like yeah
I'll just get invited to things
play video games I don't I don't need
I'm not gonna do anything but if someone
wants to invite me out I'll come you
know what I mean so yeah yeah but then
it's like you know people appreciate you
showing up as well that's very important
too but yeah you know showing people
that it's appreciated and that you you
value that time and you would like them
present that things is important uh and
that's like that I think you know the
[__] that never taught to you no no none
of this stuff I've ever talked to you
and you just have to learn it because
you're just like all right well I guess
this is what being a nice friend means
yeah but also I don't know I felt like I
learned a lot of weird things being from
a small town and you learn small town
etiquette and not not it's like no no
it's just weird because I feel that like
what do you mean just like I don't know
like stuff that was considered very
normal where you're from might not be
normal where you are right now and how
you have to kind of adapt to that and
kind of be like oh okay just because
there was a gathering every week at
maybe the pub
now I don't have that how do I make sure
that like how do I make friends when
there's no Palms like if there was a
place where everyone would just be at
yeah because there was nowhere else to
go you could reliably meet people there
it's like oh now I have to like okay I
can't just wander into a place and meet
everyone who knows everyone yeah you
know what I mean like yeah and maybe
even just growing up with when when
everyone's from a small town
um and even like the kids right because
you know when you're a kid you get a lot
of your how you think about things from
your parents yeah all the kids
I mean included you'd get like a lot of
the stuff fed to you from your your
parents and I feel like the internet is
like throwing a massive spanner into
that
um and I just remember thinking like the
whole time when I was a kid uh I was
like man I just I just don't feel like I
think the same way like everyone speaks
around me and I I think that's why I
felt like really like outcasted for a
while because I just I was like man I
want to do all this weird [__] on that I
saw on the internet and everyone's like
oh let's just yeah I like the like the
football that my dad told me to watch
meanwhile Conor's there like have you
seen poopy meanwhile she's hilarious
yeah I'm like I'm like shouting at
Americans on COD and I'm looking at all
this stuff online about Japan when I'm
like 12. this is so cool what are we all
doing yeah um but then again I feel like
that's a very weird mindset of like I
think I'm Different to everyone and it's
like maybe I'm not different maybe I'm
just a problem I don't know yeah I mean
I I got that feeling whenever I go to
you know meet uh go to Sydney's Hometown
because yeah that is that is a very use
like home that is a very small town and
it almost kind of feels like oh she's
gonna hate me for saying this it almost
um it almost felt like incestuous in a
way just because every I swear to God
everyone's known each other and they've
known each other like from birth yeah
right and then it's like that yeah and
like like everyone everyone who's a like
a everyone who's friends there are like
childhood friends and that's that's good
I think that's great because you you are
also you know that's what's the
situation there's a lot of friendly
people who you're often introduced to
throughout your life if you've often
taught a lot of social skills uh that I
think are really important whereas I
think sometimes in you know in people
who are raised exclusively in cities
it's a lot more things you should be
careful about yeah you can't just
randomly go meet the people you can't
can't just be left in the middle of a
shopping uh I don't know Supermarket
yeah and then your parents will come
pick you up later or some [__] I don't
[__] know why you do that but yeah
you you we got up to a lot of weird [__]
yeah I would not do now for sure because
because the I think the one the one
Trope I guess I'm gonna try the one
Trope I'm missing in my life is I've
never had a childhood friend you know
what is that I don't know what that
feels like whenever I see that in anime
I see like oh I I have a childhood
friend and uh there's no friends from
your childhood who you have contact even
like no you could hit no like zero yeah
Define childhood like you've known them
since you're a child yeah like since
like there's like no one you could hit
up and be like hey how you doing man
um everyone that I've known when I was
like a child like like pretty young uh
I'd say like the only friend I've really
kept in contact with the furthest we go
back is probably like end of high school
when we like going to University that's
that's like no one from like Primary
School no not a single person I can
probably hit up like
half a mile score which not a lot of
people by the way yeah
half of my year and I feel like yeah you
get a drink it'd be fun yeah uh and then
there's like three that I would be able
to hit up and be like hey man come to
Japan come hang out and they'd be like
oh yeah it'll work then maybe yeah sure
I don't have that I don't know what that
feels like maybe I don't know maybe it's
just like a city thing but you have
childhood friends right a majority of my
friends are childhood friends yeah
seriously yeah so like my mom did this
like five head move uh when I when I was
born because like you know Sydney is uh
is is a big city right and uh lots of
suburbs lots of different like Community
uh communities of different ethnicities
all over the city
um and you know my mom coming from Japan
obviously all of her friends that were
back in Japan right
um so she found when I was born she
found this like Mother's group that just
consisted of Japanese moms with like
non-japanese husbands so basically
they're like halfu kids
and they and and my mom went oh this is
perfect because a I can make Japanese
friends who live in Sydney as well and
they all have hafu kids that my kids
could be friends with as well so my mom
would basically take me my sister to
these like this this Japanese mom
Gatherings and I would meet all of these
[__] half Japanese kids who were like
pretty much the same age as me maybe
give or take a couple of years and yeah
like you know some of those people are
like still my best friends that have
known them for over [__] 25 years now
yeah and it's [__] wild like yeah
when I went back to when we went to
Australia last month for the convention
and I went back to Sydney I caught up
with some of them and it was really
weird we were just like reminiscing
being like isn't it weird that I've
known you for like over 25 [__] years
of my life and like that's that's wild
to think to me to me that's a long time
to me that's like family at that point
it is yeah they all like family for sure
yeah and it's it's great
God I wish that was me so I I I'm aware
that I I am very blessed in that
situation yeah um and if it wasn't for
my mom who again was the was the genius
that's why she's the goat no I basically
like paid to win
my mom was like I got you bro yeah I got
you here I'm gonna whale on your account
here guys he's all your friends
yeah I don't know I think also you
probably had a pretty normal upbringing
which probably helped a lot too I think
a lot of Define normal wow by normal I
mean like uh like no troubles yeah like
financially stable yeah uh I guess your
parents are still together yeah you know
I think that's like that's like a big
thing and then like just yeah I mean I'm
like Financial Security is a huge thing
as a child as a kid that I [__]
certainly didn't appreciate when I was
growing up oh yeah I was just like yeah
my mum and dad always together and uh we
never have to worry about money I think
I don't know I get an Xbox so I sounded
pretty good right yeah I don't know like
I think that's that's a huge factor in
when you're growing up right and I'm
sure it is I think definitely small town
it's a lot easier to kind of have that
stability yeah yeah there's not a lot of
weird stuff happening yeah at least when
I was growing up would you would you
guys go back to your high school
reunions
sure why not I miss my high school
reunion LED my 10-year reunion oh yeah
it happened recently but obviously I was
here so I missed out I kind of wish I
went to it really realistically I'm I'm
like no but then the ego part of my head
is like [__] yeah
you know what I mean just rock up with
two security guards oh sorry boys sorry
take sunglasses off yeah I mean you know
of course okay
to deny my ego would be the biggest lie
ever um uh but you know I also think
that when I sometimes I'm just
fundamentally I'm just a very different
person from who I was yeah in high
school and I think
you know when I sometimes speak to some
people who I feel haven't changed at all
since high school I'm like is that good
I don't know if that's good or that's
impressive like I'm not like well it
depends it depends how they were in high
school right yeah yeah I mean there's
some people who definitely I haven't
changed them they certainly should have
changed uh yeah you know
yeah I'm sure we all know that yeah of
course we all have that friend or person
we've seen who is literally identical to
how they've been living their life the
exact same way yeah yeah and you're just
like God I hate you so much and I'm so
glad you haven't changed because your
life is [__] you're a dick to
everyone yeah yeah
um
but you know there's I think it's it's
an important thing to change and to grow
and to learn maybe certain behaviors
maybe you do that you could improve upon
and I think that's something that I uh I
think also as a YouTuber you're like
forced to because everyone is well they
don't have to you can be a [__] uh
but a lot of people are always very
judgmental of you us especially we're on
a [__] two-hour podcast things we say
or yeah like Lord knows that we're we're
we get we get some heat but then it's
also like a really good thing to in in
one part of my head I'm like yeah that's
great I can actually I have like a
[__] dedicated list of people judging
everything I say and and telling me how
to improve and giving me some health
because sometimes I I maybe just thinks
things towards uh certain topics or
maybe my behavior towards certain things
is just not as good as I'd like it to be
or I could improve it in a way that
where I don't know I just I feel better
about myself or maybe it's more healthy
long term it's kind of it's kind of like
a good moral not like a good moral check
so everything yeah you know I I think I
speak for wolves I we never try to do
anything bad but sometimes sometimes
sometimes like you know you're just
living your life and maybe
you're just doing things and you're like
oh this thing I did could have been
damaging to in this kind of weight
either myself maybe people around me
because I just didn't realize and you'd
never have that kind of feedback loop to
to have that maybe some people point out
like hey maybe that thing you said
wasn't very good yeah okay and then
you're like I'm gonna go look because
yeah friends sometimes don't tell you
hey man that wasn't cool yeah because it
just sometimes doesn't happen and that's
where real friends come in real friends
and call you out on your [__] yeah
like mate you were kind of a [__]
dick and
no I'm not gonna lie yeah people like
that man yeah yeah which is what okay
one of the big things as well is uh
conflict right I feel like you know
um some people will go out of their way
to avoid you know writing so conflict is
always an unpleasant uh an unpleasant
topic and just an unpleasant experience
but I feel if you've gone through a
friendship and you've not had like
either done a little bit of like
conflict resolution you know even if
it's just a [__] stupid drunken
argument like or something like that
it's it's it's like if you're tiptoeing
around you know if you're tiptoeing
around hurting your friends feelings
then you will never know where the
boundaries will lie right you know what
I mean yeah I think conversation is a
very important part of a long-lasting
friendship and if your friend does
something [__] up it's important that
you tell them they [__] up right away
yeah because then you know I think most
people uh if I told you hey gone that
boneless chicken thing you said was not
cool
maybe you reacted kind of sour to that
you're like what the [__] what the
[__] wrong with you I didn't do
anything wrong I'd be like oh okay well
either I'm wrong or which has never
happened
or you know maybe this is someone who I
shouldn't pay much mine to and then
maybe they're like not a good friend
yeah but I think that's a great way of
just learning because I think ultimately
if someone is a really great friend they
will appreciate that you came to them
and told them hey yeah you know because
you know you you if you get confronted
about something you should take that as
oh I've clearly upset this person why
wouldn't I want to make this better why
wouldn't I want to improve the situation
why would I be getting defensive over a
situation when I you know this person
clearly feels offended for something and
if there's someone I value there's gonna
be something there that I need to
address or unpack yeah even if you end
up you didn't do anything wrong I think
it's important to at least hear them out
and and just have a conversation yeah
walk through it yeah I think that's a
very important part of being uh
definitely an adult and also knowing
when to pick confrontation I think
sometimes you can get you can get a
little too gung-ho with it and you can
find too many yeah if you get too
pedantic with it then that's just a
quick fireworks I think there's a sound
that comes with experience an age you
just you just kind of learn you're like
this is really not a big deal yeah if I
make it a big deal I'm going to cause
more problems in the long run yeah
because you know I'm sure we've had that
one friend who's maybe brought something
up where you're like what the [__] like
what like why is this even a problem why
are we talking about this yeah yeah
you're like what is this an issue like
you know we've all had that and you're
like you know and even then it's like
it's important to work through that and
yeah let's break it down like what
what's right what's going on here most
of the time it's it's not the actual
problem most of the time it's something
else it's something else that's uh
that's a deeper problem it's using that
as a Crux to like kick off the
conversation yeah yeah yeah there is
this problem by the way here's the real
issue yeah yeah yeah let's talk about
let's let's unpack that
are you good man are you good normally
most of the time when that happens there
is something not good that they might
not like be aware of that you're like
okay that's that's the right now we know
the root of the problem that's okay I
get it now I get it uh yeah some people
just need to talk about their feelings
and [__] some people just need to vent
and uh yeah okay so I I had that like
I'm that kind of like I had this like
awful I don't know if it's an awful
personality trait but it is like the way
just my mind was whenever sometimes
someone would come to me with a problem
my gut reaction would be like let's fix
it and then it took me like age to
realize some people just need to event
about that day yeah they're not looking
for a solution just want to hear have
someone listen they don't yeah they
don't want answers they don't want you
to suggest how to improve it they're
just like they're just like please just
hit me up they just need you to go
that's rough boy yeah and then end of
conversation because me me my
engineering blind would be like all
right I've heard the problem let's not
break it down and this is how you fix
this is a step-by-step yeah if you reply
to every time someone's like this
problem well I would have done this yeah
you should do this yes I I literally
used to do that and I hated that I used
to do that yeah everyone does it at one
point because they're like they they
feel like they're helping the situation
yeah yeah a lot of the time people just
want you to listen and engage with it so
just ask more questions not not in a way
of like how can I fix this but like hey
yeah well why did this person do this
why does why does that bother you why do
you feel about this yeah just just
making people know that you're listening
and hearing them and understanding them
is just so important yeah for sure this
podcast is brought to you by cash app
with tools for saving and spending it's
the best place for you to level up your
money and glow up your life video games
everyone loves playing them everyone
loves the feeling of when you level up
when you gain that brand new skill it
feels great right so I think he's sick
I'm mad you know I love a good leveling
up video game story what if I told you
then that you can have that that exact
same feeling leveling up your life death
no there's no way
all it takes to pay someone is their
phone number email or cash tag you can
even scan their QR code straight from
the app and you'll see your balance
updated immediately so you always know
when a payment went through but Joey can
I also get exclusive discounts with the
cash app pay and cash card you
absolutely can gone it is a faster
simpler way to bank without so many fees
oh my God how can I download this so if
you want to level up your life you've
got to level up your money so download
cash app in the app store or Google play
with the link in the description down
below with no hidden fees and a freezer
order debit card it feels like a cheat
code for your finances they're going to
cash out for the sponsor back to the
episode smash the description coming
back to the main topic of why we even
got on this thing why do you think
people are lonely
see again like it's a lot of it and this
is probably the worst way I can say it
but I think it's all just perspective
based right like I think there's
obviously a lot of issues that we've so
far discussed in this very deep podcast
episode about like you know what might
be the reasons for it but I think
there's a lot of uh instances where I
think people say they are lonely because
they just feel that way and there is no
concrete reason as to why that is maybe
it's based on their life experiences of
like all like their ideology of what
being lonely might actually mean to them
and then you know obviously there are
many instances where it's just something
that's out of the control like the
pandemic or are you saying that you
think
people aren't less learning them before
but their perspective makes them think
they are more money maybe that might be
the case because I feel like you know
especially in this day of uh social
media like people are more connected
than ever before and it's so much easier
to connect with people whether that be
online or IRL right so maybe this
environment of everyone is connected
with everyone at all times through
social media has kind of like raised the
bar of what is considered loneliness
perhaps or maybe lower the bar I I think
I disagree I think also I'm just trying
to I I I it's the words you said yeah
I'm processing I'm hearing the words and
I think I just yeah I I'm pretty sure I
disagree it's a really tough topic to
like you know get a full concrete yeah I
think on like a I I just I think people
are lonelier and it's not like a
perspective thing I think people just
are lonelier and I I don't think it's
like because people think they're more
lonely or whatever I think people
actually just are lonely right
um again this is all opinion yeah this
is like almost I mean this is just based
off like there's no right or wrong a lot
of a lot of questionnaires whatever
polls and stuff and you know uh suicide
rates are up as well people are just I
think factually just more lonely
um what that stems from I think is just
from like a million different issues
being yeah broken down and like feeding
into each other and the pandemic was
like all right let's raise this to yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm sure the pandemic
like did a lot yeah to make people
realize a lot of things
um and I you know I just think there's
there's always just been this less
emphasis on being social and uh just
because I think that we've been afforded
more luxuries that allow us to be less
social and it's easy to adopt like you
know more technology that allows us to
be less social and we didn't really
think like is this going to impact us at
all no it's more convenient let's just
do it yeah
um and then you have
countries like Japan where they're like
hey well we've been lonely for a while
so let's just let's just make a solution
that you can pay for like let's just go
to you can pay to go out like you can
pay to go and hang out people you can
yeah you can hire people to hang out
with you you can go to a bar and pay
people to talk to you it's like and it's
like this really weird kind of like
let's not worry about why people are
lonely let's just let's just throw the
solution yeah yeah and let's not address
that's not like get to the root of the
problem yeah which is like which I think
when we're talking about loneliness in
our perspective we're talking about it
from a western perspective of loneliness
um right which is why I'm kind of
curious to be like I wonder how much
worse it is because it's probably a lot
worse in Japan like in terms of like the
rate yeah I think that it's also
important when we talk about it like
that is to think about where that
loneliness comes from and I think why
Japan is lonely is like a mixture of why
a lot of people in the Western countries
think the lonely combined with the
horrible worth worth yes life balance in
Japan yeah that also comes back from
from even like school life where you're
kind of robbed of a lot of your free
time I think I think it's like are the
reasons why these two countries are
lonelier like inherently different but
also then technology is like fueling the
Flames of [__] enough for everyone
yeah yeah and I'm not this is not like a
doomerism of me being like man
technology bad I just think it's like
it's impossible to adopt all this
technology and not think hey how is this
affecting us because we're just too busy
being like let's [__] let's use it
well let's just [__] adapt it let's
put it in let's [__] [__] this all
let's do some calls all the time yeah
you know I mean I think you know it's
the meme is like oh look Boomer say
technology bad haha let's laugh at him
the reasons why this is technology was
bad was totally different to why yeah I
think it actually is bad yeah yeah right
like they're saying because they were
just like I don't understand it well I I
do I do feel that you know it's not
technology isn't inherently the bad
thing the bad thing is our self-control
we're not able to adapt yeah is our own
self-control right uh because it's it's
not like social media's fault in per se
you know social media is just a platform
you know
um but you know being addicted to social
media being addicted to you know having
having what is their fault yeah having
having these tools that are available to
us to combat the loneliness without
actually combating the loneliness but
like like tricking our brain to making
us feel a little less lonely without
actually having like you know maybe
giving us uh maybe uh maybe Arsenal
actually going our way to find a real
human connection that's that's part of
like partly on us to be like we are too
lazy yeah I mean I feel putting the
effort in too many people are like
blaming the tool and not the user yes I
don't know I I that's kind of tough
because I think that a lot of these
platforms use way more data than than
they ever should have to perfectly
engineer solutions that like hack our
brains to keep us glued yeah right and
in a way that maybe if you had if it was
present in a different way you might not
be as in as uh addicted to it it's like
you know do you no so yeah what I'm
saying is I'm not trying to blame the
user what I'm saying is you need to be
like aware of this you know there needs
to be more Consciousness about this
thing because we actually we actually
see it like the amount of like you know
I'm aware that like that it's addictive
and it's still addictive like I can't
it's not stopping me from being addicted
okay you know you're addicted but like I
see like I think the worst case I see
with it which is like ironic which is
like when parents get really addicted to
social media and like websites it's
actually like I feel like it's like 10
times worse than when like people our
age or younger people getting into
social media because what I've seen
parents addicted they are they it's it's
like they don't even know it's a problem
you know yeah like you know some you see
some parents that are on Facebook all
the time and they have changed literally
changed their viewpoints based on like
some [__] articles that they see on
Facebook book and they get like I've
seen like now families literally get
divided because of some [__] Facebook
posts that people make well yeah well
that's like I mean that is like I think
the social media's fault because they
were you know they they knew that
posting outrageous [__] and they would
they would help bump it because they
were like oh this this drives engagement
yeah and people engaged something with
most when they're pissed off yeah so
let's keep fueling this [__] up [__]
and let's keep pushing in front of
people and yeah not everyone is you know
and it's I think it's their fault I
think some people are just more
susceptible to
stuff that is just inherently like wrong
or
that you know like fake fake news and
[__] I did not get into all of it I
think we just are more susceptible say
oh a lot of people who are more
susceptible to that than others yeah and
a lot of these social media platforms
weaponize that to drive engagement yeah
because they also probably realize that
if you get someone to be super engaged
with the topic oh like the flickering if
you get someone to be super engaged with
the topic they'll push more about it
they'll be on the platform more looking
more interacting more and then so it's
like this kind of really like
self-fulfilling prophecy of like just
kind of vile behavior that they're kind
of giving people hooked and keeping them
in with all this [__] and connecting
them then to other people who've also
been fed the [__] as well and
they're all spreading it as well yeah
yeah yeah so yeah to get back to your
original question sorry I do like you
know I said this earlier but I do think
just because there are more tools
available right now that trick you into
thinking you're not as lonely uh as you
actually are yeah when you're not
actually forming the connection to
actually combat the lonely that's yeah
at its core and that's what I think
that's that's what I think and then a
double A double-pronged attack on that
is that let's say you you uh you feel
lonely and you recognize you feel lonely
from from maybe not being have that
connection uh you know a lot of the time
what do we turn to when we want to try
and make those connections we go online
yeah and I think a lot of these there's
a lot of websites or a lot of
um people kind of prey on that
loneliness then offer them a solution
online be it you know you're lonely
romantically his dating websites yeah
where you might get connected with
catfishes or people trying to scam you
or you know all weaponizing Learners
yeah God knows what the nice loneliness
it's like how
Tinder would Tinder forever I believe it
still does this I I'm not sure but
Tinder at one point in time and again it
could still be doing this
um you know if you were an older male
who uh was maybe less attractive you
would be charged more for Tinder gold or
plus whatever are you serious yeah you
could charge way more money
um [__] hell and then they they you
can you can look this up kite but they
were basically they were basically like
depending on how in demand your profile
was you'd be charged a different amount
yeah and you know then they would be
like oh you're not getting matched as
much you know there's this thing called
a super like you know or uh there's a
you could you could pay at one point on
Tinder to be the top profile right two
hours which then they'd be like we
promise you more matches it's only it's
only 30 bucks to do this you know but
you might be the love of your life
what's 30 bucks you know yeah so they
would kind of weaponize your loneliness
and and I think that not blaming the
platforms is I I [__] I fully blame
the platforms for the the predatory
behavior they get they got away with
doing like they tender should have never
ever been able to do that like the fact
that they were able to charge you more
because you use the data to then
weaponize and target people who they
knew were lonely and who were desperate
yeah and be like hey I know you're
lonely and desperate and you're ugly as
[__] no one wants to love you uh and
you're never gonna get married or find
someone because
pay to win yeah but if you pay us 100
bucks a month and on top of that you
know it's still not enough you know you
can do this [__]
more expensive
yeah so it was more expensive people who
were undesirable wow um ageist
I fell off man and that's like a really
like that's an obnoxious kind of look at
what they're doing right that's an easy
thing to point to but I think I think
that a lot of the platforms are doing
stuff like this where they are targeting
people who they know are more lonely and
more likely to spend or more likely to
give them screen time uh and then they
they use that and I think that's
something that is like something that is
just so hard to address that
is very hard to and that in a political
sense it's also really hard to get like
get any meaningful change done because
they also hold a lot of power and we
also rely on these platforms a lot yeah
and it's you know it's like if you're
Googling how to make friends you know
Google then starts serving you ads about
hey meetups near you just pay ten
dollars to join the platform or stuff
like that and it's like yeah or maybe
you know
it's like you get targeted on Instagram
by fake accounts from like catfishes
like obviously that's like the lowest
and low and there's hardly anything
sophisticated but yeah you know there's
just people are always willing to take
advantage of you and that's that's like
a [__] place right now that just
didn't happen before like my my [__]
parents didn't have to worry about
someone trying to [__] sign up to a
dating website and charge them [__] [__]
ton of money or didn't have to worry
about if they had enough friends it was
like no you should make friends you know
there's so many friends you could make
and you have to worry about being
catfished or this kind of [__] yeah you
know what I mean like there's just so
much weird [__] that we we're so quick
to like sweep under the rug and not
address because it maybe doesn't apply
to us uh and I I don't know it's very
frustrating because I think that God
have all Boomers do it people lose
empathy people lose so much empathy
towards other people when they're when
they're in a good position yeah for sure
it's so easy for you when you have
friends to blame people who don't have
friends like you blame them be like no
no you're you're completely at fault for
not having friends it's like maybe you
weren't set up right and then maybe
maybe you were given no chance in life
to make friends and you were never given
a good chance uh from your you know your
parents set you up to fail and then on
top of that everyone's taking advantage
of you and and then maybe the people who
were in place to help you just failed
you in every way yeah maybe your people
like teachers or people who should have
been there to be able to help you have
just failed you and I think there's a
lot of I it's just frustrating that
people aren't empathetic towards uh
towards that you know and it's easy to
sensationalize people who are who are
[__] up and who have caused their own
problems like look at these guys they're
causing everything wrong in their own
life yeah and everyone else must be like
yeah yeah right yeah we demonize people
a lot because we we like I think people
who um are doing well you know like
we're doing well it's very easy to be
like well we did it it's all us just
make friends
we solved all of our own problems okay
and it's such a bag of like it's so
tough because I do think that we
as individuals we are very proactive and
we have definitely taken opportunities
to to try and give ourselves the best
chances yes but also we were very lucky
in a lot of Senses as well I think okay
but I guess you're you're like no no
you're you're making like such great
points uh there's so much just like I
could throw at this and it's like I
think about this stuff a lot and it's
yeah it's so hard because it's so hard
to determine what's okay tangential and
what's important for me for me it's less
of uh yeah for me it's for me it's still
okay so my kind of like this is like
just like my personal philosophy right
for me it's less of a haha look at all
these people they're not they're
obviously not putting in yeah like
effort in you know you know you know
obviously technology companies like you
said are definitely predatory especially
when it comes to just hacking our
[__] brain oh yeah yeah what I'm
trying to like what my approach to
pretty much everything in life is is
um I can only control what I can control
which is like myself so my my kind of a
whole philosophy is less of like uh when
when I have a problem in my life you
know
um I kind of I kind of try to approach a
problem of what can I do to change
myself because I can't guarantee that I
can change the world to fit into like my
boundaries but
everyone is yeah everyone is born with
different circumstances with different
like advantages disadvantages uh and you
can't always control that so my personal
philosophy has always been what can I
control in my life to make my life and
myself the best person and version it
can be that's that's the monk in you I
know I don't know because I I agree with
you no I totally agree yeah yeah so I'm
not trying to say like oh don't blame
the technology companies or don't blame
this don't blame that don't blame this
I'm just like okay if I was in some
other person's shoes this would be my
approach to it because I can't I can't
change the way that Twitter or Facebook
promote their [__] I can't control the
way that they try to hack your attention
and do all this but I can try to control
myself if I want to make if I'm feeling
lonely then what can I do about it I can
put my I can try to put myself in a
situation where I can be more social
hopefully make more friends down the
line that comes as a bonus but the first
step to me will always start with me
yeah I think that speaks to your
upbringing though like I think your
parents distilled a lot of really like
good values indeed because I just think
a lot of people just don't they just
don't see the world that way right yeah
I think I feel like yeah for a lot of
people that kind of like disciplinary uh
you know like self care uh that you know
the the beliefs that you have is not as
naturally integrated into people as
other people right it's like I feel
that's a skill that you either had to
have grown up with or you just have to
have like realized from a young age yeah
because because especially with the
internet when we're talking about like
complex situations like this there will
always be that side where someone is
genuine only
um in a bad position they've been [__]
over in life and they've been [__]
over by those people around them and
then sometimes you see on the internet
where you there's definitely someone
with like a victim complex oh for sure
like 100 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know it's it's hard to like just
distinguish sometimes on the internet
just because no matter what the internet
has made us been able to connect with
every kind of person from every Walk of
Life so my My Philosophy with all of
this and my advice has always just been
the first step is just focus on yourself
because you cannot especially with the
internet with the scale we're working
with now you cannot everyone's in a
different situation you can't you can't
have a one or solution for everyone you
can't change the algorithm on the screen
but you can change the algorithm up here
that's that's it baby that's what it is
that's what it's all about that's what
it's all about
yeah for sure yeah yeah I I think it's
just always the main main thing I was
trying to get to is just yeah you know
it's always just really important to
never lose that empathy
online allows us often to just cut that
off we don't want to deal with it if you
don't want to be empathetic towards
other people sympathetic in any way I
think it's too easy to fall into that
and uh yeah just don't yeah
empathy empathy is a thing that is uh
losing more and more yeah value as time
goes on yeah it feels like
a lot of the social climate that we're
in right now is like weaponizing the
lack of empathy against people to to you
know to kind of incentivize some uh to
kind of benefit a certain group people
it's like well don't don't worry about
them because they they do it themselves
you know we we did everything right you
know we're good don't don't worry about
them like yeah Spread spread any [__]
lies you want and also like people just
do it for like their own kind of selfish
self-satisfaction right yeah of course
yeah it's like ah well well I mean
that's your guys's problem that's not my
problem I don't give a [__] about that
you know you can deal with that I'm
gonna live life in my own way right
which is like it's yeah it's pretty
[__] selfish like and unfortunately
there's a lot of people nowadays who do
think that way because they're like well
I don't I'm already dealing with [__] in
my life yeah I don't have time to deal
with [__] in other people's lives and
it's like well I mean you can
technically yeah as the goat once said
you have no enemies
that's it that's it that's such a good
Mantra though [__]
probably like my favorite meme that's
come out in like the past year it's so
good
oh my God but like I think it's uh you
know I do definitely feel like blessed
like you know I think I have enough
self-awareness to feel to see the spots
in my life that I have been very lucky
in as opposed to some things I've like
worked more towards
um I feel very very blessed that I have
found like a partner because one thing
that [__] that has like always been
like
so like something outside of my
uh let me rephrase that something that I
could never see myself going through
is just the adult dating world right
because I've okay so I obviously you
know no rizz no rizz
I was lucky I was lucky enough to meet
Sydney at a time of my life before I
entered like the whole professional kind
of dating world yeah I mean I'm a rank
data I'm correct what I mean by that is
well when you are a [__] working
adult and you have to manage your time
and your love life yeah uh for me like I
managed to meet like all my you know
previous Partners through kind of like
more let's say not not natural but more
Hobbies yeah it it it wasn't like uh
when you didn't have a nine to five yeah
when I didn't have a nine to five it
felt more uh there's a word that I'm
that's better organic organic that's it
yeah in a more organic way than just
going on an app and being like we are
going to meet for a date at this time
and see if we're romantically interested
in each other you know I've never had a
meaningful connection from anyone I've
met like Tinder anything right yeah
because you just never I don't know why
I think I just went into it I was like
oh it's just tenderness I was never like
considered it like that I don't know I I
I mean that's saying that was probably
going in my brain where I was like this
is just not I just don't see this as
serious yeah yeah I mean I I doubt the
majority of people who use that website
do take it serious to be honest I mean
you know there are some instances
I have a friend from high school who met
his girlfriend on Tinder and now I
certainly believe you can and you know
Tinder loves to [__] use that story
whenever they can yeah yeah this could
be you yeah but you know and then you I
never I never everywhere near those
[__] some people on like this really
serious dating websites where it's like
you would have to answer like a 900 part
survey and answer how like this yeah and
stuff and you're you're awesome
websites it's like that that's I don't
know to me that's like that's too much
I'm like that's like now you're trying
to gamify something that can't be
gamified right yeah like there is no x
equals y here it's like you just you
kind of vibe with someone just figure it
out man I'm farming love points right
now but that also comes back to like a
societal pressure of like we're always
taught you have to be in a relationship
yada yada you have to get with someone
it's like I don't know who [__] cares
yeah and it's like you know that's tough
though because sometimes people even
when they know they shouldn't be they
feel societal pressure they just do and
it's impossible for them to somehow get
out of that
is there a difference between a need to
finding like a partner and horniness
is there a difference between wanting to
find like a partner for life like
marriage yeah kids and family or just
like a one-night stand okay
so this survey okay so this survey that
Phil said right it was like uh more men
feel single and lonely it's not just
lonely it's single unload right right so
are they uh dude what does that mean
does that mean that they uh it means
they have no risk it doesn't mean that
they need more rizz or does that mean
that they are missing a partner in life
that's they probably both I think you
can be in a relationship and be done
yes 100 yes
on the flip side I believe you can be in
a relationship and be horny as well
it's just you know
I may have shot the goal but my wrist is
still at an all-time high Maybe
you know like you know which we there
there is definitely a lot of like
married couples out there that might
have you know lost the flame and uh
literally every Japanese couple that
like uses like a [__] soap land right
like that's literally it the
in a relationship but they still want to
[__] yeah so it's genuinely like what
know what are people looking for
nowadays like are they desperate what
are they more desperate for because I
feel I see let's say a lot of thirsty
people pop up in my timeline you know
every every now and again we we see it
we're now we're now getting into a topic
of hammer you know is the access of porn
is it harmful like just having too much
damaging to you well no no it's like I
guess a lot of the times I'm you know I
think if anyone anyone interests me like
porn should be banned I'm like shut the
[__] up especially but it's like I think
there's a legitimate thing of like is
consuming far too much porn does it do
something yeah there's a limit like yeah
yeah you know for sure it's it's just
like it's like a [__] coffee it's
like yeah you can you can abuse coffee
yeah like I think but I don't think if
you look in the guy that does this yeah
but I think like people who would be
like we should ban coffee it can be
dangerous like shut the [__] up yeah
don't [__] get a [__] grip get on
my coffee shut up you know just don't be
horny don't be horny going back to you
you said about loneliness and Holiness
yeah I think what that meant was like
people who were single and lonely as in
like maybe they didn't have any
meaningful connections and they were
also single yeah right not not that they
were horny and sing okay okay okay what
do you asking because I think
they were getting no [__] in every
sense of the world so you can you can
like okay gonna go okay so
um let's say you're that's this is so
stupid okay let's oh we're here let's
discuss let's say you uh you're one of
those guys that identified yourself as
single and only okay what were what were
you more desperate to look for to what
what void were you trying to fill were
you trying to fill the horny void or
were you trying to fill the connection
voids which is what a lot of people I'm
mistakenly assume that you fill both
with the same thing
oh that's
it yeah
well that's the thing I feel maybe for a
lot of those people loneliness can
equate to either one or both yeah you
know I'm sure there are some people who
are just like I don't really have
interest in like you know finding a
partner or or a wife and a husband and
you know starting a family or anything I
just want someone who's there for me uh
to you know you know maybe fulfill my
sexual you know frustrations or you know
like maybe lack thereof any kind of
human Connection in that sense yeah and
then I'm sure there are some people who
are like yeah I'm kind of done sleeping
around I just want to find someone that
I can just love for the rest of my life
and start a family with right yeah
because like I you know in in my life I
have known like a few Lads a few guys as
well who you know they would uh their
top priority wasn't so much finding a
let's say a real like
relationship or like a like a partner
they just wanted to find someone anyone
you know and it and no no it's like like
just some like a partner just to like
feel that void of not having a partner
there yeah and it was less of like is
there a real connection there and it's
more of okay this is a partner who I can
you know I can obviously sleep with
because we're we're in a relationship
um but also they're kind of just there I
kind of just want that void to be filled
and that was more like just having
someone there was more important than
finding the right person or the right or
you mean Japan
no I think it just means just present
just somebody who's just oh someone's
just in there in your life yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I've met like several
people like that in their life who if
they're not in a relationship or even if
you know especially someone who has just
not been in a relationship period
they're just kind of looking for anyone
to fill that hole you know well I mean
again like that's the whole reason why I
like soap lands in Japan are so [__]
popular and because like people Japan
has just figured out oh I need someone
there even for a short period of time to
like you know make sure and reiterate to
myself that oh I'm not lonely and Japan
was like well you can do that just pay
to win bro and then you got it it's all
it's all it's all pay to win Brooks
there will be there will be someone
there for you whether that be a soap
land a hostess club a host club any kind
of like [__] Cafe cuddle Cafe
whatever it may be there's so many
different varieties of it now in Japan
and it's like yep here you go it's from
from zero horniness to level 100
horniness we have everything on the
Spectrum you can choose it's just pay to
win yeah and I I and I've always like
I've always wanted because I you know
was very little kids because you know
when I was growing up I was like I'm not
gonna get married until I'm at least 35
in my mind right in my mind that's what
I thought my life path was going to be
y35 I don't know that just that number
just felt like
what I thought when I thought I would be
ready right you know settle down and
settle down with a life partner in my
mind
um and I you know life doesn't always go
the way you think it's gonna go
um I thought I was going to meet my life
partner way later in life and you know
have way more time before I actually you
know tied the knot but I ended up
meeting Sydney way earlier than when I
thought I would
um and I have you know I found someone
that fills everything I've wanted to in
a partner so
um I that's where I recognize I'm very
blessed so because I didn't have to go
through the you know Tinder phase or
just like the phase where the date game
the date the Day game where I'm working
but also I have to like try to find time
to find love in my life and that's why I
asked the question because because I've
never been through that stage in my life
I'm like what do people look for they
are they more looking for are they
looking for a real human connection or
are they horny do they just want to [__]
and they and they want to [__] which is
totally fair you know I'm a guy as well
I get horny as well I [__] get it you
know it's it's like I it's more of like
a genuine question I think there are the
three of us are the only one who has
experience
I'm kind of in the same pool party
no you just whatever it is that I mean
it depends where you're at in your life
really because like your priorities and
what you're looking for change uh
all the time uh I would just go on dates
because I thought that was what I was
supposed to do yeah I was like I should
I just couldn't date people that's why I
was you know [__] like I'm sure uh
there's something in your life where
your parents like oh you seeing anyone
and it's like that kind of that kind of
conversation arms are yeah right like
like like
that is a thing that will always be
asked and like that and it's not even
just Asia I think every every [__]
yeah yeah
Asian mom's like tenfold they're like
yeah are you seeing someone are you are
you dating anywhere and it's like that
that little question that gets asked all
the time by a lot of people in your life
kind of and you're always yeah you
always ask this in your life kind of
cements this idea for a lot of people
that you have to be with someone you
should be dating you should be looking
and so I think there was never a point I
think in my entire adult life there's
always a point where I was either you
know uh dating or just looking okay but
messing around
um or in a relationship there's always a
point where I was doing one of those
just I thought that was what I was
supposed to do yeah yeah like I was like
oh yeah this is what I do and I think I
would never question why I was doing it
or what I was looking for someone you
know sometimes you be in these dates and
be like what do you want I'm like I'm
[__] know
I'm just trying to make YouTube videos
like I'm not concerned about this like
this is not where I where I'm at right
now they'd be like I want to get married
I'm like well I'm not the guy you know
and a lot of a lot of people a lot of
people have you know they're like yeah
like you they're like I don't get
married to this age and they they change
a lot I I was always the camp of like I
am I do not care about getting married
and I'm not getting mad anytime soon and
I'd mean it to them and I I think they
would be like I could change him I'm
like I don't know I could fix him I need
to say that now I I am absolutely not
you know the financial implications of
this this is a nightmare to do like I am
not doing this
I'm her I'm her yeah you know and it's
like I like I think why people date is
always different like I think a lot of
people also
you know a lot of guys and there was
definitely a time in my life where I
thought this was the case where it was
always Associated from movies and stuff
growing up that the cool guy was the guy
who got a lot of girls you listed around
right yeah and I feel like this this is
caused this idea of toxic masculinity
has caused so much more Fallout and then
we can even comprehend I feel because I
realized I caught myself kind of falling
into that trap of thinking that way yeah
and I feel like I'm a pretty self-aware
guy and I'm I and I was like God this
and then you look online I feel like
this is where a lot of incel kind of
like uh rhetoric has come from this kind
of stuff and I feel like this idea has
caused so many [__] problems
um and you know you've probably met guys
now like you've mentioned to this day
who still have that idea of I should I
should look around I should date as many
girls as possible yeah because that's
cool that's what a cool guy does yeah
double standard right yeah and like it's
like it's it was honestly when I was
dating the most people was I was
probably the loneliest I was like this
is like I'm forming no connections above
like one day like this is such a no no
no let's not say that like [__] it's
like it would just be like I would just
go on a date a single time maybe nothing
happened a bunch of the time I was like
90 you know and then I would just be
like wow what a [__] waste like I
didn't even try and build a meaningful
connection I would just meet up with
people one time and never talk to them
ever again yeah sometimes the [__]
isn't worth it it wouldn't even be for
like that right I would just be like I
would just be like I would literally
turn up I would lose an entire day spend
a bunch of money and I would get
literally nothing out of it yeah I was
like why am I doing this to myself like
I don't I and then you know after a
while like I just kind of want something
I kind of want to like have something
meaningful yeah yeah of course or you're
just like oh you just like hold up
maybe I just need time for me maybe I
just need to step back from all of this
yeah I think I think a big thing is that
a lot of guys feel like they need you
can certainly not they they need to have
a relationship in order to feel let's
say fulfilled or to feel like not lonely
you know and I'm like it's an easy way
to think that if you're lonely that it's
the easy answer I think for a lot of
guys yeah because a lot of the times for
some people it can be but I think for a
lot of dudes like you're saying it's a
super easy thing to go for right away
yeah like this is my loneliness yeah and
then maybe when you you get in the
relationship you realize I had a lot
more problems than I I realized I had
because this relationship is not working
out yeah there's a lot of unhealthy
things going on here and I'm I'm
woefully I'm prepared to address these
yeah um it's it's only when you're in a
bad relationship do you realize how good
a good relationship for sure for sure
yeah very very grateful for a lot of my
terrible relationships the whole [__]
lot same here same here it's made me
appreciate it's a good thing when it's
like presented right in front of me you
know that's that's uh that's the big
thing you know you know it was as a
teenager you're so kind of like uh
pressured even if it's not like
even if it's just like maybe a fake
pressure or maybe like a fake
expectation just to like find a girl and
like lose your virginity as fast as
[__] possible right I mean that's
that's the thing though that's the thing
at least when I was a [__] teenager
you know I was like I think it was like
the American Pie yeah the [__]
American Pie you know it's like
you're going to prom you're going to
prom and you're not losing your
virginity what the [__] especially at a
[__] boys school Jesus Christ this is
every if I like after school so all
right boys we're gonna go get some
[__] [__] yeah I'm just like bro
just don't I know just stop don't play
me and now I just look back at that
moment of time and I'm like I just
cringe because I was like yeah okay yeah
I'm a horny teenage boy who's probably
reaching Community you know yeah I think
losing my virginity is one of the
shittiest experiences
it was one of the just the worst yeah
everything I was like really awful yeah
it was just a bad time I was like this
nothing inherently bad about it it was
just the most underwhelming everything
was [__] yeah I was [__] yeah they were
[__] everything's [__] uh yeah it was
just all all on terrible terrible time I
don't think anyone I don't think anyone
walked away from the situation happy
right yeah it's I I've heard like a lot
of losing your virginity stories
including mine and every everyone's had
like the same reaction of just like that
was it that's what everyone [__]
hyped up really really no I thought it
was pretty high oh [__] of course Joey
of course God God damn it well I mean I
I lost my virginity like I guess I don't
know when is the period that is like the
most suitable to lose your virginity
because you know there are a lot of
instances I lost my virginity late or I
lost my virginity early like what is
what is that time trick question there
is no suitable yeah that right it's when
it just [__] happens exactly and when
the Lord deems it
I was like Jesus is so now the time okay
thank you I don't think there's a
correct time I think whatever you feel
comfortable with because I'm sure
there's a lot of people out there who
may be rushed into it yeah probably had
a horrible experience and probably
regretted it yeah I see my experience
wasn't terrible like my experience
wasn't like [__] traumatizing it was
just yeah it was just like that was a
bit [__] wasn't it yeah like it was that
kind of hard it was like it was in like
and it was and it was purely because I
was just like go go let's find a way
I've got to get at it if you don't mind
if you don't mind sharing how old were
you uh I I was I was 17 17. yeah how old
were you 18. it's okay I'm the oldest
but I I was 22.
actually I think it's I think the
considering the fact that you had like
the most positive experience out of us
yeah uh probably like just don't be in
high school when you lose your virginity
be an adult I'd had other experiences
before that yeah
um and that was definitely like oh well
this is weird
because I I didn't know the [__] I was
doing yeah I'm a [__] kid yeah yeah
um yeah I mean I I will say probably
it's not all media and social pressure
uh you know there is a point when you're
a teenager where hormones definitely
creep up you know yeah absolutely and
you're like holy [__] what is
what the [__] is this going on I need to
fix this
immediately oh God oh my God oh God see
you guys you guys were like you guys
were like you know there at the right
time and you knew the solution where
it's like okay I know exactly how to do
this just you know get laid Yeah so I
had that exact same idea it's it's just
like I had negative reasons yeah so I
couldn't I couldn't get it as much as I
want to say boys we live in a society
okay okay that's true
having negative risk does not [__]
matter there are there are people who
you're probably uh sexually attracted to
is like a teenager when you're both
teenagers obviously yeah you know when
you're both teenagers they also probably
had negative written you know yeah it's
not only the good looking people who are
getting [__] done you know what I mean
in school like I have negative rich and
I I you know we would I'd date other
people with negative wrists and it was
just [__] awkward yeah yeah we would
just have a time maybe that's it maybe
maybe I knew that I was like oh if I
date someone with negative wrist well I
also have negative risk then it's just
not even gonna be wrong it's just like
I'm so glad I I [__] everything up
when I was a teenager because I was like
I didn't know what this was and like one
time dude just like learning [__]
because you're just a [__] idiot kid
yeah that was inside classified I'm a
tall kid and uh I don't know how this
conversation care about because they're
like something something Simon and I was
like yeah only girls have that right
yeah but I'm like man I'm a [__]
idiot no one told me what the [__] was
like I got my whole [__] adult life
uh Teenage life not learning what the
[__] was because I come from a [__]
small ass town and I wasn't researching
this by the way ladies I'm single like I
would look online but I I would I was
not the kind of dude who would like I
like dude there was I I don't know if
it's just like a weird thing and I feel
like maybe maybe kids get into this way
earlier like when I was like 15 I was
not Googling [__] about like sexual
stuff at all no I was too focused on
games
way too way too focused on these
priorities so I didn't even like I
didn't even give a [__] about porn or
anything like that until I was like 17.
yeah I just didn't give a [__] because
this is not what I was interested in so
when I was trying to learn all this [__]
I was going in blind I was like oh my
God what is happening I am I have no
idea what is that I just remember like
watching porn
o
the first time I was like I have no idea
if I'm doing this right yes I think this
just feels all right do you remember
your first time jacking off yeah
I do I remember distinctly I don't know
why I have this memory I was playing
Halo Reach I feel like I've had this
conversation no we have not had this
conversation this is when Halo Reach
came out and I remember the exact map I
was playing on before I jacked off
for the first time I remember the setup
I I just remember that like I was
playing Halo Reach which means I must
have been when did Hitler reach come out
can we get it we'll get it we're gonna
go
yeah it was it was late I didn't start
jacking off till later yeah 2010 so I
was I was 14 so probably it came out I
was probably like 14. yeah that sounds
about right I was about that age yeah
and I remember being like when I when I
was you know because you you heard how
do you learn to jack off your friends
just always talk about it right no dude
I hurt myself the first time I did it
yeah what the [__] you're doing yeah and
the only way I'd learned is because I
heard about it from my other friends who
were like oh yo jack off I'm like yeah
me too and I was like what the [__] is
that I was doing it like I was starting
a fire I was like
because I was like I know you have to do
something but I was just like I'll just
[__] do this
I was like this hurts I'm gonna go Bear
Grylls yeah
yeah and they wouldn't they wouldn't
tell us anything about what it was and I
used to just think that like random [__]
was sperm I'd be like this shot this
thing on my dick this must be spoke and
I'm like what the [__] no this is not
shrub this is not sperm at all and then
everything the first time I I managed to
this is so over over detail after
someone managed to like [__] jack off
successfully mission accomplished I
remember being like oh what the [__] is
this [__] oh get the [__] out of here
what the hell she's nasty and I didn't
know that was gonna happen
you don't learn about having tissues
oh my God what the [__]
stop please unprepared yeah I don't know
I don't know did you have like a stage
because like how I like uh how I like I
guess learned because uh I guess uh I I
remember like getting my first time like
get it you know getting getting an
erection right yeah I don't remember the
first time do you remember no not at all
I feel like I think I just got because
you know you just you just gets hard
right yeah yeah like your dick just gets
hard randomly and like and like it would
be like a nuisance for me because I I
would not I would not understand why
this happened the whole time I actually
was just seeing brother and sister
he is a pretty little things to come
yeah so so like remember the first time
I got one I was just like uh what is
this uh what the [__] is this and then
like uh you know I wouldn't do anything
because I didn't know how to jack off
back then so um I would just like wait
for it to go down and yeah for it to
pass and I didn't get why this would
happen because it would be like really
inconvenient for me just to have like a
massive [__] you didn't just like say
boobs and we're like oh no no that's
what happened
generally sometimes it would just like
you know it's sometimes it just [__]
happens especially especially as a team
for no reason but no reason Bono uh that
that was just like My Teenage life yeah
I was just like this is uh this is kind
of like inconvenient uh this take up a
lot of space in my trousers and I don't
know why it's happening uh so I
basically one time I was just like I'm
gonna try and get rid of this somehow so
he was a literal like it was a literal
troll by Era first I started like trying
to [__] smack you [__] smack it
away it's like stop yes stop
and then they'll and then like well and
then like buy trial and error
um I just realized wait why does why
does this feel sensitive I don't get it
and then it just and then it's just like
oh is this that jacking off people
talking about
we've had [__] smacking it yeah I'm
just genuinely curious now how people
how people find this [__] out you know I
don't even remember how I figured out
like oh that that is not the right way
to do it I'm like I think I can't
remember I think there's just so much
information out there yeah where you
don't need to worry about having to
figure this [__] out yeah because you
couldn't be told how to do it oh I think
I think I think I remember why I I
remember at the correct way to do it
because I was like my friend was like
showing me this Pawn on his phone and
like you know back then another thing
that teenagers do that's weird yeah yeah
on the [__] school bus on the way to
school and you know like it was the flip
phone so it was like [__] 240p you
can barely see [__] anything on this
tiny screen he's like check this [__]
porn video out it's pretty sick and I
was watching it and I remember
specifically it was like Johnny Sins or
someone I don't remember but there was
the male guy and he was like j-oing and
I'm like that's how you do it
oh no wonder this [__] hurt
that's not how now I
fathom a world where you thought you had
to do that I I don't know I was just
like this makes this just this makes the
most sense this is why you had no
[__] yeah this is why I had negative
rims because I was [__] jailing
you just [__] unlocked a core memory
yeah you you uh because I I completely
forgot about this but like even
um I think it was like before I learned
how to jack off yeah right like so I
think I discovered porn before I
discovered how to jack off and I didn't
make the correlation yeah yeah I think
me too yeah yeah
uh because I remember like uh we uh I
had a sleepover one time with my mates
right and normally on most sleepovers
um normally on my sleepovers we just
play [__] N64 and just uh play uh
Super Smash Brothers uh until like the
[__] sun comes up or whatever not
that kind of Super Smash Brothers the
actual the actual the Nintendo video
game the video game
um and then one time um
my mate was like oh can we uh can I use
your PC and uh he starts downloading
porn on LimeWire and I had no idea what
the [__] he was downloading and he
downloaded this like [__] like yeah
you know obviously we're on dial up at
the time so we downloaded he downloaded
this like one like one minute clip which
you know too still took a while yeah and
he shows it to me and I got like my
mom's just having this realization of
this one sleepover that we're having as
a kid and he shows it to me and it's
like the most [__] amazing thing I've
ever seen in my life there are three of
us and we will just stand we were just
all sitting back dude look at it like
monkeys we're just like gorping and I
was just like I turned on me and I'm
like is that like a full version of this
and so the entire night we are uh we we
find the full version of whatever clip
that he's uh he's found it's like a 20
minute clip takes all night to download
yeah uh we stay up all night this is the
most mid-2000s it is it is it is uh play
a place of video games didn't get any
sleep that night
um and at around I think like 5 00 a.m
we could start to see the sunrise out
we're like oh boys it's happening it's
finished and the last thing we do want
to sleep over and like my mum and dad
are asleep like upstairs and stuff we're
just all like huddled around we're all
huddled around in silence just watching
like watching this porno and it's like
it's the most amazing thing I've ever
seen in my life I'm like
[Music]
what is this
I don't understand
and uh is this what crazy is yeah
and uh that guy ruined me for my uh for
my life because I was like well now I
know uh now I'm only downloading one
thing on LimeWire and it ain't music
anymore
oh God did you have any um uh
pregnancies in your school
uh no because I went to a boys school
that would have been
that would have been a difference
privileged no but like uh because we had
the I went to the boys school and then
down the road there was like the sister
school which was the all-girl school and
yeah there were some stories of like
people getting pregnant in the sister
school I don't know we
um had quite a big push on like sex
education yeah we had that too because I
think the area I grew up in was like the
I had like the highest rate of teen
pregnancy in the UK oh damn uh probably
there's nothing to do oh yeah yeah
um so yeah I remember there was like I
think yeah one or two in my year I think
but I remember the other they just
randomly I think started really pushing
it being like hey guys use condoms I'm
like bro I don't even know how to jack
off how do you think I'm gonna figure
this [__] out what are you I I don't
know I'm gonna play Halo Reach I'm not
I'm not worried about this I'm trying to
get those next Point Sports yeah I felt
like we had the we had these Lashes in
dinero it was like catered towards
specific group in our schools I think I
was just like bro I'm just trying to
learn dude every time like for me that
the thing that annoyed me was like you
know during sex education they were like
okay guys remember if you're going to
have sex which is nothing wrong about
because you're all in puberty make sure
to use a condom and in my head I'm just
like where
how how do you require these things I've
never even seen them out in the world
who has
been from you didn't tell [__]
just like the
one when you think about having sex it's
like you got to go out and buy them but
they never taught me where to get them
so I'm like well thanks for that
information
um I'm gonna do nothing about that I'm
gonna go home and play Mario party
let's turn into games yes yeah nothing
else is happening yeah exactly hey look
at all these patrons though make sure to
use a condom whenever you have sex yeah
um hopefully you learn how to jack off
better than we did yeah let us know down
below yeah yeah let us let us know how
you jacked off we've cursed this common
section holy [__] this was an
interesting episode it turned into it
went from one of the deepest episodes to
just like three monkeys talking about
like jail yeah
but uh Hey if you like to support the
show then go to our patreon patreon.com
trash days also follow us on Twitter
send us some memes on the subreddit I
can't wait for the means of this one if
you hate her face listen to us on
Spotify
and we'll see you guys next week bye
[Music]
foreign